I'm very highly educated I know words I
had the best words Trump speaking style
is informal it's casual familiar basic
and simple it's characterized by folksy
words bad job out here folks I didn't
need to do this folks we have some bad
Umbra's here and we're gonna get him out
his speech style includes non words
Bom Bom Bom and he often produces
incomplete sentences
Wow in the face with a padlock a lot of
damage yeah I never did it if speech
were a form of clothing Trump will just
stubbornly be wearing jeans even in this
situation where the dress code requires
a suit bomb data for bringing up that
kind of they're fully there are two main
theories about why Trump speaks like he
does one is a deficit theory this
highlights the fact the Trump frequently
produces a word salad the words are just
tossed together proponents of the
deficit theory argue that Trump's
disorganized speech is the product of
his disorganized mind you know what
uranium is right thing called nuclear
weapons and other things like lots of
things are done with uranium including
some bad things nobody talks about that
the second explanation for Trump's
verbal output is a different theory
Jared suggested that the simplicity of
trumps language is merely a rhetorical
device or flattering and connecting with
voters and we are all making America
proud we are rocking we are
if you transcribe an unscripted speech
by Trump it often seems like gibberish
cheating on trade cheating there's no
other word for cheating they responded
with silence they didn't do anything
they were silent Silencio let's not rock
the boat oh that's because it's not
intended to be transcribed it's part of
an oral not a written tradition this
isn't really surprising because even
though Trump's a published author he
isn't a great reader of books my second
favorite book of all time what's my
first favorite book the Bible the Bible
Trump's failure to finish his sentences
mirrors how we often speak to our
friends in informal settings we often
cut short our sentences on the
assumption that the other people
listening will complete them in their
own head so by not finishing his
sentences Trump is treating his
listeners as if they were his buddies
stay on point Donald stay on boy when he
was on the campaign trail Trump learned
that the best way to build rapport with
an audience is to involve them Trump
singles out individuals that Trump do
what he has to do that's my guy
right there look at my african-american
over here look at him and he makes the
event feel like an unscripted
conversation there's a soap you get
those teleprompters out of here we're
gonna have some fun right dad does
Talent bronchus Trump wants the audience
to know that he's on their side he often
does this by complaining about
politicians politicians are all talk and
no action
no politician is gonna solve it
politicians are liars Trump taps into
the negative feelings that he supporters
share and he doesn't pull any punches
either one of trumps pet hates is
political correctness we don't fight to
win we fight politically correct words I
am so tired of this politically correct
by targeting political correctness Trump
is saying that it isn't afraid to speak
his mind
we don't want to be too politically
correct anymore right folks we have
become so politically correct though we
don't know what the hell we're doing a
tax on political correctness pretentious
champion free speech but they're really
coded messages telling Trump's base that
is okay to hold intolerant or bigoted
attitudes Trump has a habit of
announcing that he's not going to say
something while he's actually saying it
so I refuse to say that I cannot stand
her screaming into the microphone all
the time is this rhetorical device is
called Apple faces it lets Trump plant
an idea in people's heads without taking
any responsibility for what are you
saying
now once there was because of me but it
was okay I won't do it I was going to
say they're foolish
but I won't say that now it's true it's
true
I won't say this mystery strategy allows
Trump to present himself as a lovable
Road Trump likes his speeches to seem
unprepared when he wants to sound more
official he sometimes refers to himself
in the third person nobody respects
women more than Donald Trump probably
nobody's been tougher to Russia than
Donald Trump
this mobile technique is called ilysm
Trump uses it to give an air of
objectivity to what he's saying to make
himself seem much more important
so we'll see what happened we'll see
what happens remember what I say we will
see what we will see Trump likes to keep
his listeners in suspense says that they
hang on his every word keeping everyone
in the dark ensures that the spotlight
remains firmly fixed on him and that's
exactly how Trump likes it one of trumps
favorite phrases is believe me believe
me believe me believe me not all of
those people were neo-nazis believe me
this phrase is typically used by people
who are very confident its Trump's way
of being emphatic he's trying to
persuade his audience to take him at
face value Trump also loves using
intensifiers so easily so easily and so
smartly I'll say very honestly and I'll
say it very straight words like very and
so underline the point he's making
together with expressions like believe
me they give his speech forcefulness and
energy very very strongly very very
strong very very strong when Trump
approves of somebody or something he
tends to use words like beautiful and
tremendous they can be taken care of
quickly beautifully the story was
beautiful
there's tremendous tremendous potential
much of his language of approval seems
extreme some of its out of place this
has encouraged these suggestions the
Trump is susceptible to what
psychologists call dichotomous thinking
where he's inclined to see the world in
binary as black/white good or evil us
versus for them we're gonna win so much
you're gonna get tired of winning you're
gonna say you know this guy's winning
too much a major dichotomy for Trump is
between winners and losers what a bunch
of losers I'll tell you call them losers
I said call them losers you are a loser
you really are a loser for Trump winners
are life's heroes losers are simply the
pits he's a war hero because he was
captured I like people that weren't
captured okay I hate to tell you if you
examine the words that Trump uses to
describe the people he genuinely admires
they're all extreme forms of adulation
he's a very honorable guy in an honest
guy high quality he is perfect
references to the people he dislikes or
just as extreme leaders are stupid our
politicians are stupid they're gutless
they're all gutless they are the most
dishonest people in the world the range
of positive words that Trump uses to
show approval is actually quite limited
but the range of negative words he uses
to disparage people is remarkably rich
and varied feels much more comfortable
knocking people down rather than
building them up but there's a faith
that's almost as bad as Trump score and
that's his faint praise and I like him
he's a good man I always liked Michael R
yeah and he's a good person when you
describe someone as a good man or a good
guy it's usually because he's annoyed or
he's tried to dissociate himself from
that person
very good man thank you good man Bridget
so if you're trying to buddy up to Trump
beware if he calls you a good man you
know you haven't a hope in hell you can
bank on it
I'm really rich I share that necessary
for most of his life Donald Trump has
been a property tycoon a man who's
accustomed to giving orders and having
people follow them this is obvious in
his power talk the words he uses and the
self-important way he refers to himself
I am going to be the greatest jobs
president that God ever created
I do get good ratings you have to admit
that I could be more presidential than
anybody I can be more presidential
anybody Trump has also enjoyed a
successful career as a reality TV host
and this too has shaped the way he
speaks you're fired you're fired
[Music]
Trump's language has been his experience
as a deal maker his default mode of
engagement is selling that's what I do
my whole life has been deals I've done
great at it as Trump knows all too well
the first rule of sales is to identify
your target market we won with poorly
educated
I love the poorly educated makes no
bones about it is customers on
disgruntled conservatives and in what a
leader doesn't mince his words like to
punch him in the face I'll tell you the
next step for a Salesman is to identify
the needs of the customers America first
drain the swamp we will make America
great again
you have to convince everyone that
you're the only person who can satisfy
those needs because I used to be part of
the club I'm the only one that can fix
it I alone can fix it
what we're selling is not enough to blow
your own trumpet or even to get others
to do so for you you need to make sure
that your potential customers aren't
considering alternative providers lyin
Ted Cruz folks remember that crooked
Hillary Clinton he was a dirty rotten
dessert that's a low-energy individual
folks trucks attacks of designs to
single out his rivals weaknesses and by
implication to make him look much more
attractive like the only realistic
option no better word stupid stupid
these are stupid people Trump seems to
recognize that when it comes to selling
there's always a hidden quid pro quo
which is that people are prepared to buy
what's on offer provided that the sales
pitch involves a novel and engaging
spectacle due to construction worker all
politicians employ the principle of
selling no politician however has
exploited these principles so blatantly
or with such enthusiasm as Trump he may
give the impression that he's offering a
political vision of what he's really
doing is selling selling is himself I
did a great job this weekend